the Saudi Arabian Ministry of Foreign
Affairs they issued a very lengthy
statement in response to Biden saying he
would reassess America's relationship
with the kingdom after OPEC announced
their massive oil production cut and the
Saudis well they had some thoughts on
Joe Biden now first they accused him of
lying about their motivations for the
production cut then they say that he
wanted the Saudis and OPEC and also that
now includes Russia to delay their
announcement and their cut by one month
this is what they wrote postponing the
OPEC plus Russia decision for a month
according to what has been suggested
meaning requested by Biden would have
had negative Economic Consequences next
they put Biden on notice that they're
not going to be listening to any of his
quote dictates actions or efforts to
distort their work on setting oil prices
and if that's not humiliating and bad
enough if Saudis had some parting words
for Biden we are not friends the kingdom
affirms that it views its relationship
with the United States of America as a
strategic one that serves the common
interests of both countries wow here now
with reaction Florida Senator Marco
Rubio is on the Foreign Relations
Committee Senator this is my
interpretation of that statement my
interpretation is is that Joe Biden was
told in no uncertain terms not only will
they not increase the production of oil
but they're going to cut their
production of oil and then Joe's answer
was well can you just delay the
announcement a month uh and that leads
me to conclude the very strong
possibility that Joe Biden was trying to
collude with the Saudis with OPEC plus
with Russia and OPEC nations to prevent
this information from becoming public
prior to a midterm he's had a far uh
conspiracy out there conspiracy uh
Theory or is that accurate
well I think the pieces begin to fit
first of all they've already played
politics with oil so obviously he runs
for president he threatens he's going to
put everybody out of business so of
course the refining capacity the
production capacity almost a billion
barrels of oil less today than we were
when Donald Trump was President then you
have them start dipping into the
Strategic reserves and we have these
strategic reserves after the OPEC after
the OPEC Embargo of the two of the 1970s
because we never wanted to be in that
spot again those things are there for
things like hurricanes or War some other
disruption they're not there for
midterms that's what he was using it for
then we get into this situation now
where Saudis and others are acting in
their best interest I think they're
doing two things here one they want to
set oil prices at a way that is good for
them and at the same time and it's opic
plus Russia but the other is they're
doing it to punish America and Joe Biden
and we shouldn't be in this position we
are an oil producing country if we want
to be the reason why we are not the
reason why we are producing a billion a
million barrels of oil a day less than
we used to is because the Biden
Administration will not allow it to be
produced and the radical left in the
democracy credit that controls the
Democratic party has told the fossil
fuel industry oil and others we are
going to put you out of business and we
find ourselves in a position as Beggars
the most powerful country in the world
is now in a position of having to beg
these third-rate countries okay
so he's begging these countries that
hate our guts oh you know we could we
have more natural resources as you know
than all these countries combined we can
be energy independent for hundreds of
years this is a problem for me uh Joe
Biden for some reason thinks it's okay
to Mother Earth that we import oil but
we can't produce it domestically my
question though is specific here because
the Saudis didn't like Joe's comments
about reassessing the relationship after
they cut production of oil my question
is why did Joe Biden then ask them to
delay their decision delay their
announcement he knew they weren't going
to cooperate and that in fact they were
going to cut production why did he want
it delayed until after the midterms to
me the answer is obvious I think we need
a congressional investigation you're you
would be a perfect candidate for it to
lead it into whether or not he was
trying to collude with foreign countries
to get influence in the upcoming midterm
elections
well I don't think there's any doubt
that the timing tells you that the
answers your question right we like can
we just not do this or announce you're
going to do this until after November
because the last thing he wants is
what's happening already what happened
over this weekend a spike in oil the oil
prices go up in the Futures market and
then a couple weeks later it begins to
get priced in at the pump right around
the time is Americans are going to go
vote and remember Biden's been going
around and the Democrats have been going
around for weeks bragging about how all
gas prices were coming down everything
was on he was taking credit for that now
he'll have to take the blame and he
deserves the blame so yes I believe
they're messing around with it for
political purposes but I also think this
is an indicative of how these radical
left-wing Marxist Misfits that control
the Democratic party have put us in the
position that we are now in as a country
and that is they're okay with us getting
more oil from other countries they just
don't want it produced here and it
leaves us vulnerable not just on oil but
on all kinds of other things that they
refuse to produce in our country natural
gas all the byproducts that come from
that you name it you know it's it's it's
really a shame Senator I can't believe
we've been put in this position and look
at this the suffering in the American
people every time they fill up their gas
tank they feel it every product they buy
at every store they go to will cost more
to produce and it costs more to
transport it these are scary times all
of it preventable if he would have
stayed with the Trump energy
Independence policies uh Senator Rubio
your race in Florida is critical if
Republicans are to have any chance at
holding the Senate and get a majority We
are following your election closely I
know you're up but we'd like to see a
win by double digits if possible
well we want to win big I need
everyone's help please go on my website
Marco rubio.com I need your help you bet
Senator thank you for being with us hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else